hey guys
i'm happy to be here so i'm heidi zack
the founder of third love
and a little bit about my background i
started my career
in investment banking working with
retail companies and
went from there to mit for business
school i was president of the retail
club went from there to aeropostale in
new york i was a director
i launched and ran their international
business
and then went from there to google and i
was at google a few years and i left
google
two years ago to start third love so
we're backed by some really great vcs um
raised five and a half million two years
ago
uh a little bit about their love before
i get into press and how to get it
um so at third love we're
revolutionizing the lingerie industry
it's a 35 billion dollar industry
worldwide it's huge
um third love came out of my frustration
at buying a bra
for any there's some women in the
audience for men in the audience who
don't really understand how it usually
works you
go to a fitting room and an old lady
comes in and you're half naked and she
measures you with a measuring tape
and then she yells at you and says
you've been wearing the wrong size
that's usually how it goes
um it's not cool it's not fun and that's
why women don't like to
get fit for a bra so basically i said
there's got to be a better way
and what we've done over the past few
years is build an app
and patented smartphone technology that
lets a woman size herself for a bra from
home
i know it sounds crazy it actually works
so the way it works is a woman puts on a
tight fitting tank top and takes two
photos into a mirror a front photo and a
side photo
and we're able to calculate the size of
her body in relationship to the iphone
so we tell her her size her measurements
and then she can shop we also use that
data at an aggregate level from all
these women who use our sizing
technology
to create more sizes so we have 30
percent more sizes than any other brand
on the market
just a little background over the past
year since we've launched we've spent
virtually
no money on paid customer acquisition
we've spent under twenty thousand
dollars we've really really focused on
press
and telling the customer our story
and building word of mouth referrals
this is just a few examples of the press
we've gotten
good morning america is probably the
biggest success
that they have a viewership of five and
a half million every morning
so that was huge for us
so everyone out in the audience um if
you're going to start a company
whether it's b2b b2c or you are a
founder
we all face the exact same issue right
and it's
how do you get your brand noticed it's
such a noisy world
and how do you acquire new customers and
at some point in time it may be early on
or later in your company
you're going to rely on press and
perhaps a pr firm to help you do that
so i've talked to probably every founder
i meet about their pr firm and i always
ask them do you like them
and literally 80 to 90 will be like not
so much
so people generally are not happy with
their pr firms you hear this over and
over again it's not easy to find one
to pick one or to manage one so i'd like
to save you all some hassle
in your lives and tell you a bit about
what i've learned along the way
so when we launched we were actually
pre-launched so we didn't have an open
website it was really a closed beta
this was a year and a half ago i was
looking for a pr firm that could do all
of these things right that could do
tech and consumer press and fashion
right
and i was talking to these firms and
they sold me that they could
this is a lie so you need to understand
that every pr firm they're good at one
thing it's either
tech press or fashion press or whatever
design
it doesn't matter they're good at one
thing so as the founder of the company
take a step back figure out what your
main goal is what are you trying to get
across what's the press that matters
for you are you raising money do you
need to get tech press
are you a company like ours with product
where you need fashion press figure out
who your audience is and then pick a
firm that focuses on that area
so now that you have your list of your
top firms
how do you figure out which firm to work
with
it's called the back channel reference
right we all know what the back channel
reference is we use it for hiring all
the time
um you know that's how you find out
whether this employee who you supposedly
think is going to be awesome in
joining your team is going to be a great
fit it's really about
what somebody says who who they didn't
put on their reference list
so you have this list of pr firms look
at their
clients and then go find founders who've
worked with that pr firm and reach out i
mean through your network right you
probably know a lot of founders
or just reach out linked linkedin short
little note just tell me
in three words how were they were they
terrible were they good or were they
amazing that's all you need to know
they'll get back to you so this is an
example
of a founder i reached out to and you
can see what she writes back
hi there terrible fire them okay moving
on
um here's another one he gives a bit
more detail about three firms he's
worked with
um and you can see one it's what he's
really raves about he says they're
amazing one he kind of says is good and
the other one again you see the same
word used
and i've heard it a lot in verbal
conversations too founders will be like
they're
terrible so just an indication don't
spend your time talking to these pr
firms at the beginning
back channel referenced them before
don't waste your time
and then last here's a pretty decent
reference on a pr firm that we ended up
using where
the founder says good not amazing better
than most so this was pretty good for me
i was like all right i'll actually talk
to
this pr firm all right so you have your
pr firm
now you're going to pay them some money
and you need them to do something for
you right
this headline here is for third love bef
when we announced our fundraising we
announced our fundraising and again we
were pre-launched so we didn't have an
open site or app yet
um and you can see there's two messages
here
right there's a message about our
technology and then there's a message
about our fit
and what i learned from this is a lot of
things
two things two main points one is when
you have too many messages
the press will pick up on whatever they
want to pick up on so in this case they
really picked up on the app and the
sizing technology
and that was really great but it kind of
lost the message about our product
quality
size and kind of that consumer point of
view
the second point i want to make is about
timing okay timing's everything
when we launched we launched in the tech
press and then good morning america
called
and when good morning america calls and
asks you to go on tv with your product
what do you say right you say of course
this is awesome yes i want to be on good
morning america you
it doesn't even really cross your mind
as a new founder to
to take a step back and say is this the
right time for me like
is this the right time for good morning
america um
i really wish if i could do anything
over again
this is one of my top things i wish i
had said
no you know we're not live yet we'll be
live in two months
let me come back to you and you can have
an exclusive on our launch when we
actually have the website open
so i didn't do that good morning america
covered us it was awesome but
i think the timing was off a little bit
back to the messaging when we launched
our new pro a new
product line about eight months ago we
stayed very focused you can see this
message is really tight it's
specifically about the product and
everything in the press release
was really really tight around this one
message
so the results of that were that
we got press that talked about
fit that talked about comfort that
talked about how amazing our product was
in
all the publications that we wanted to
hit um this was
really the best type of pr we'd had
and then lastly this is really important
so
whether you're reaching out to press on
your own if you don't have a
have a pr firm or whether you have a pr
firm
seed your product right the best kind of
reporter
is one who loves what you're doing
they love that product or they love that
experience so
get your product out there and make them
love it because then they're going to
want to write about it
so dana cohen here is the senior fashion
editor at instyle
we uh we sent her 24 7 bra before it
launched and then
she tweeted this right okay at third
level i'm sold your bra's perfection
awesome and then below that is the email
that she
um sent me and she says there's a frenzy
in all caps over this bra in the office
and you can read the whole thing
and then at the end she says this will
be my call out bra
right this is huge so what ended up
happening from seeding the product
and her loving it is that we got an
imprint feature for this bra
and in style this was amazing for brand
recognition customer acquisition
everything we could have possibly wanted
so i'll just leave you with one
additional point and that is
when you're thinking about building
relationships with reporters think about
it in the same way you think about
building your network with vcs for
example right you need to do it over
time
develop a network develop an authentic
friendship with them
so that when you're raising money you
have people to talk to
it's the same thing with the press you
want to build an authentic relationship
because
as reporters move from one publication
to another or as you move
from one startup to another you'll still
have that relationship and be able to
leverage it over time
hi heidi thanks my name is ramon with a
smart hustle magazine
and can you talk to those who are out
there i work with a lot of main street
small businesses who don't have a sexy
product no pun intended
a hot product something that's
interesting but the boring
you know accounting from a law firm i i
have a manure business
how do they get pressed because i think
yours is a good job an unfair advantage
everybody wants it it's interesting
talk to those who are boring um i think
even a boring business
has interesting components so i think
it's coming up with something newsworthy
and stats tend to work really really
well with reporters
so say like a local business it may be
like the amount of pizza
people consume or hot days of the month
for buying xyz
and really try to get the reporter
focused on like a tidbit
because then they'll create a story
around it and then a second idea is also
to combine businesses together to make
more of a story so it's not just
pitching i'm pitching third love but
maybe i'm gonna go out and pitch
um really cool direct to consumer
businesses so it's not just third love
but it's a bunch of other ones so i
think that also works
thank you yeah great thank you
you